NADAV: Hi, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
Good afternoon and welcome
to Talks at Google Cambridge.
I'm honored today to
introduce Samantha Lakin.
Samantha is a Cummings
Foundation fellow and a PhD
student at the Strassler Center
for Holocaust and Genocide
Studies at Clark
University and is
alumna of the Fletcher
School at Tufts University
and of Brandeis University.
She has interviewed and
research Holocaust survivors
as a Fulbright
scholar to Switzerland
and is a grantee
with the National
Endowment for the Humanities.
She continues to work with
the World Health Organization
on worldwide gender issues.
Samantha has
presented at a number
of international
conferences, including
the University of London,
the international Institute
for Holocaust research
at Yad Vashem,
the Museum of
Tolerance in New York,
and the International Society
of Political Psychology.
She's a consultant for the
Kigali Genocide Memorial
and the Aegis Trust in Rwanda
and on the advisory board
of the Genocide Survivors
Support Network.
Samantha's research
explores the stories
of survivors of the 1994
Tutsi genocide in Rwanda
and how their experiences affect
their current communities.
She focuses on
memorials, rebuilding,
and the transitional justice
of the Rwandan community.
Please help me welcome
Samantha Lakin.
SAMANTHA LAKIN: Hi.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much
for joining me here.
My name is Samantha
Lakin, and Nadav said,
I am a current PhD
student at the Strassler
Center for Holocaust
and Genocide Studies
at Clark University.
And what I want to
do today is give you
a little bit of
information and insight
about my journey working
with survivors of genocide
and conflict and also looking at
issues of transitional justice,
of how societies recover from
conflict and genocide to peace.
And I'm going to do that
in a very special way, what
I feel is very special.
I'm going to do that by taking
you through a number of themes
and stories that highlight the
post-conflict and post-genocide
landscape in Rwanda
today, to give you
a sense of those types
of places and spaces
that I've been able
to enter while doing
this work for the past six
years and to help you rethink
and reframe your own
conceptions of post-genocide and
post-conflict justice,
whatever that means to you.
And I'm hoping that by
the end of this talk,
you'll have seen some new
things, seen some new sights
through the photos, much
most of which I've taken,
and also learned to think
a little bit differently
about the successes and
challenges that we often
experience through the media
or through other stories
that we've heard sitting
here in Cambridge
and how they affect
people in Rwanda
and around the world writ large.
So the talk today is
called "From Genocide
to Dignity and Justice."
And basically, the main
questions I want to address
are these-- I want you to
think about what themes make up
the landscape of
post-genocide Rwanda.
And don't worry if you don't
know too much about Rwanda
right now, because I'll be
giving you a bit of information
in a minute.
And the second
thing I want to do
is challenge us to rethink
our framing and assumptions
about conflict and recovery
and to use the stories that I'm
going to tell you
and the experiences
that I'm going to share
with you to understand
these realistic goals,
developments, challenges,
and areas for
future involvement.
And while I was speaking
with Nadav beforehand,
this subject sounds like
something about genocide
and death, my goal is actually
to get us thinking differently
and reframing our ideas and
conceptions about what recovery
means to a place where
we're not sitting depressed,
thinking about how Rwanda was
in 1994 but we are thinking
about ways that transitional
justice and other justice
initiatives can really
help societies recover,
and thinking about that in
a realistic and focused way.
So when we think of
post-genocide Rwanda,
what comes to mind?
Is it something like this?
Or is it something like this?
The first photo is from one
of the National Memorial
sites to genocide
in Rwanda and shows
some of the scars and the
bullet holes, for example,
on the skulls of
genocide victims.
This contrasting image
speaks about three women
who graduated from
Agahozo-Shalom Youth Village,
running and having
fun in their village
on the day of their graduation
in their cap and gown.
So very contrasting
images to get us started.
So I want to give you
a snapshot of Rwanda.
So basically, Rwanda is a
country in Eastern Central
Africa, and I'll show you a map
in a minute, where there are
about 12 million people living.
The languages are
Kinyarwanda, English, French,
and some Swahili spoken.
Most of the country is
Catholic or Protestant,
with a small minority of Muslims
and non-affiliatedd religious.
It borders Burundi,
the Democratic Republic
of the Congo, DRC, Tanzania,
and Uganda, but what's amazing
is it's approximately the
size of the state of Maryland.
So
when you look at the map, if you
haven't seen where Rwanda is,
you'll be pretty amazed.
That little red dot in
the Central East of Africa
is the country of Rwanda.
Looking at the entire continent
of Africa, that small map,
that small red dot is
the country of Rwanda.
So it's very small
territorially.
And I want to give you
a little bit of history
about the genocide in Rwanda.
I don't want to focus too
much today on the history.
That's not what I'm here to do.
What I'm here to
do is really help
bring you into some spaces
about the reconstruction
and reconciliation
processes in Rwanda.
So I'm going to go through
this a little bit quickly.
If you have questions at
the end, please let me know.
But I just want to
give you a background
so you can have an
understanding of what happened.
So in 1994, there was a genocide
that took place in Rwanda.
The population at the time
was about 84% Hutu, about 15%
Tutsi, and about 1% of
indigenous Twa people.
And the story goes
that-- the history
goes that the Belgian
colonial powers helped
construct these identities--
Hutu, the majority, Tutsi
the minority, and also
had put Tutsi in power
as indirect rulers during
Belgian colonization.
And this created a lot of
conflict between the Hutu
and Tutsi communities.
And I'm saying communities
because Hutu and Tutsi are not
exactly ethnic identities.
In Rwanda, everybody speaks
the same language, Kinyarwanda,
and had come from
similar backgrounds.
So these divisions
were not particularly
salient or meaningful until
the Belgian colonizers
came to power.
So again, they favored the
Tutsi, who basically they
gave a lot of positions to you
in government and in education.
And after that, the Hutu
extremist government
came to power in the
First and Second Republic
and started to persecute the
Tutsi population between 1959
and 1994.
In 1994, on the 6th of
April, that Hutu hardliner
president,
Habyarimana, his plane
was shot down on
the 6th of April.
And on the 7th, the
Rwandan Armed Forces
and the Interahamwe Militia
started the systematic killing
of Tutsi and moderate Hutus.
And as we know, many of us who
were alive during this period
or who were watching the news,
the international community
really abandoned Rwanda.
We've even seen recent articles
come out in "Foreign Policy"
that heads of state
in the United States
knew what was going
on and were concerned
about calling it a genocide
because of what intervention
would mean.
And so these debates are
ongoing, but in Rwanda people
generally feel that
the United Nations
and international
community let them down.
So the killings began, and
there were about 100 days
of genocidal killings all
throughout the country
with very popular involvement.
So killings on the ground,
we call it low tech
killing with machetes and clubs
and other household and farming
weapons.
And on the 4th of July in
1994, the Rwandan Patriotic
Front and the Rwandan
Patriotic Army,
who had been in exile
in Uganda, came in,
took control of the
capital city of Kigali,
liberated the
country, and started
to form a transitional
government.
So that's the history
we've got of what
happened during the genocide.
So the current RPF, Rwandan
Patriotic Front-led government
and the state in
general, has really
attempted to rebuild social
order and social fabric
in Rwanda since 1994.
And the goal of the state
with regard to survivors,
which is specifically
what I research,
is threefold as
identified by the state--
to provide security, to combat
genocide ideology and denial,
and to reunite the country
under the Banyarwanda,
that we are all Rwandan, we
are all one Rwandan people.
And these ideals
are very prevalent
and have been there since the
end of the genocide in 1994
and are heavily present
in the reconstruction
that we see today.
So just some statistics
about survivors before we
get into the meat,
the good stuff, where
we're going to enter
into these spaces
and I'm going to tell you a
little bit about these themes
that I've identified
and the stories that
go with them, the experiences
that I've had being in Rwanda
and being with different people.
But we have about 1
million genocide victims,
Tutsi and moderate
Hutu massacred in 1994.
About 300,000 survivors,
with 58% women,
64,000 or 65,000 orphans,
widows, rape victims, children
born of rape, which is a major
issue right now in Rwanda,
and also handicapped.
So these are some of
the scars that have
been left after the genocide.
So these are the
spaces of healing
that I wanted to speak about.
And I've identified
basically five categories,
broad categories,
that I've really
experienced that are taking
place in Rwanda today.
And as I said, they have their
challenges and their successes.
And what I really want
to do is to introduce you
to those challenges
and successes
so that we can gain a really
comprehensive understanding
of how to even start
thinking about post-conflict
development.
You won't be experts
by the end of the day
but I'm hoping to give
you something to take away
that will allow you to think
about how you envisioned
post-conflict
societies and what you
might think after this lecture.
So spaces of healing,
development, recovery, truth,
and grief and Rwanda I've
identified as memory, justice,
youth and education,
psychological health and trauma
healing, and technology
and research.
I'm also not going to try to
give you the standard examples
today, the ones that you've
read in the news or the ones
that you've seen
a million times.
What I'm going to
try to do is take you
through my experiences
over the past four years
and help, again, enter
into these spaces
that are little known and
that you might not otherwise
be able to see or access to help
us broaden our understanding.
So I want you to
take a deep breath
and look at this really
beautiful photo of a sunset
in Nyarubuye, Eastern Province,
Rwanda, where my godbrother is
from and survived from.
And I want you to just
take a minute before we
enter into these themes.
And think to yourself what
does post-conflict mean or look
like?
We saw those two photos.
Does it look more
like the skulls?
Does it look more like
the graduates, the women
who have graduated high school?
What does it look like to
you right now, before we
enter into this moment?
OK, I think we're ready.
The first theme I want
to address is memory.
And I want to
introduce you to Omar.
This is Omar, who is standing in
Nyamata Memorial Church, where
nearly 335,000 Rwandans were
massacred in early April 1994.
And Omar, at 10 years old, was
only one of very few survivors.
As he was a child, he was able
to hide under other people
who had already been killed,
and even was beaten on his legs
and had to remain
silent basically
to prove that he was dead before
the Interahamwe left, and had
escaped out of the church and
into the community of Nyamata.
But what was amazing is I
have known Omar professionally
through the NGO world
and never really knew
about his survival story.
But one day, we were
eating lunch in Kigali,
and he said to me,
Samantha, I know
a lot about your work
documenting testimonies
and I'd like you to
come with me to Nyamata
and to actually walk
through the site with me
and document my story.
And I thought to
myself, oh great.
This is wonderful.
It'll be good for my research.
It will help my friend
Omar go through his story.
But I didn't really
realize how incredibly
difficult and
emotional it would be,
not only returning to the site
but also returning to the site
with a survivor of the site
who was also my friend.
And so these issues
of memory were
at play, not only the surface
issue where I can go in
as a researcher and document
people's memories of the place,
the second element is not only
am I documenting the memories
but it was in the physical space
itself, which was very intense.
And the third element
was, this is my friend.
This is someone I know and
care about and work with.
So those three things
were at play in my mind
as we began driving out of
Kigali toward Bugasara, where
the Nyamata Memorial Church is.
And in this photo,
Omar in the church.
The gray banner is
a memorial banner,
and he's looking down
at the benches which
contain victims clothing.
So those are clothing that
were either left in the church
or brought to the
church from victims who
had died during the genocide.
And you can see he's thinking.
And he's actually standing in
the place where he survived.
He survived on the bench
that he is right in front of.
And what was pretty
amazing about documenting
Omar's story is the
kind of liberation
it had for both me and for him.
For me, I was trying
to be professional
and not to cry when my
friend was telling me
about his experiences,
which included listening
to the children
and women who were
at the back side of the church
by the altar, who were crying
and screaming for God.
He was hearing all of this
and was recounting this to us.
And I felt like I
was causing him pain.
I felt like I was poking
him with something sharp
and hurting him.
And I didn't want to
cause him any more pain,
but he had asked me
to do this and he
wanted to document
the story and continue
to take us throughout
the church and tell us
about these experiences.
And there I was, trying to
be completely professional
for my friend but inside feeling
like I was really causing him
pain and that was really
hard to deal with.
And so we ended up recording
this in a video form,
and Omar now has it to share
with his future family,
future children, etc.
And it ended up being a
really powerful experience
but it took me really out of
my element where I usually
interview individuals
who I haven't met before
and who I don't know and don't
have a prior relationship with,
trying to understand their
relationship to memory
and justice issues in Rwanda.
So this was very different.
And what it showed though was
how important the memory was
to him, that he
wanted to do this
as a way to honor his own
memory but also to keep it
for the future.
And so one of the themes
that I wanted to go through
with memory is that
this Nyamata Memorial
site is one of the six national
memorial sites in Rwanda,
and there are also many
the local memorial sites.
They're often like this,
with survivor's clothing,
skulls of survivors, caskets,
and other things left behind.
But to bring in some of these
good things and the challenges,
I wanted to talk
about the purpose
of having these memorial
sites and having
annual commemorations
around them.
So commemoration
period begins in Rwanda
on April 7th every year and
lasts for about 100 days.
And there are many local and
national commemorative events.
And during the commemoration,
we have testimonies,
poetry read, official
speakers from government
and from other communities,
often a comparative lens.
And most of the
population in Rwanda
take part in these
commemorations.
And so to get us
thinking, it's really
about what is the purpose
of the commemoration?
At one point, it brings
survivors together
and it provides a validation
of the harms they've suffered.
It can educate people.
But sometimes there's also
this retraumatization.
Sometimes, there are
state goals or other goals
that are at odds with
survivors' goals.
And one survivor who
I spoke with last week
when I was preparing
this told me
that people can be in the same
physical commemoration spaces
and be commemorating
and remembering
different things, which I
think is something really
interesting to think
about, how people
can be experiencing
the same event
yet be remembering it and
having different reactions.
So that's one of
the challenges, is
how to make
commemoration inclusive
and bring everyone in.
So this is, for
example, something that
happens at the commemoration.
This is a photo I took of
some of the candles that
are lit as people sit in
these white plastic chairs.
And you could have anywhere
between 500 to 1,000 people
at one commemoration.
Sometimes, there could be 30.
It depends on the
type but I just
wanted to give you
a small perspective.
The next thing I want to
talk about is justice.
Justice is a huge, huge subject.
And part of the
benefit of justice
is that it is a large subject.
So we don't have to be limited
in the ways in which we
think about justice.
And I know I'm not
going to do justice
to the subject of
justice today, but I
do want to give you a
little bit of history
and take you into the spaces.
So again, this Nyamata
Memorial Church.
You can see those
benches and you
can see the wreaths that have
been laid on the ground there.
So this is a bigger
picture of the church.
So memorial sites are a
form of symbolic justice,
which is one way
to bring justice,
especially to survivors.
So in transitional justice,
we often think about courts.
We think about international
criminal tribunals.
We think about local courts.
We think about the court system
when we think about justice.
Automatically, when
we say justice,
our mind goes to the
lawyers, and to the judges,
and to the court systems.
Which is good, and there are
many, many positive benefits
from the court systems,
including holding perpetrators
accountable.
One of the things,
though, that I focus on
is what happens when
the courts close
and when there is no
longer juridical justice.
And that's where these symbolic
efforts, such as apology,
and memorialization,
and commemorations
come into play, which really
focus less on perpetrators
and more on survivors.
I just want to go through a
story of a woman, Bernadette,
who I met interviewing during my
fifth research trip in Rwanda.
And we were sitting on the
grass at the back of the Nyamata
Memorial Church.
It had been an
hour long bus ride
and we really had come,
my interpreter and I,
just to interview Bernadette.
Now, Bernadette was a
caretaker at the memorial,
and most people didn't
pay attention to her.
They didn't know
about her story.
But when I met her and started
speaking a bit of Kinyarwanda
with her, I realized
she had a lot more
to discuss than
might have let on
with her basically
being a janitor,
having a cleaning role.
And I remember this day sitting
barefoot on the grass there,
the three women, me, my
interpreter, and Bernadette,
asking questions about
memory and justice.
And she told me,
basically, that she
had been hiding in a place that
was unfit for any human being.
She was hiding in a
hole in the ground
underneath some
large banana leaves.
And the Rwandan Patriotic
Front eventually found her.
And she remembers them
picking her out of there
and bringing her to a safe
spot and picking the bugs out
of her clothes and hair.
And she defines this as
her sense of justice, which
is the human decency
that she was treated
with in that moment
of despair, when
she thought that the world
had forgotten about her.
And so it's from
that perspective
that I take an
understanding of justice,
that justice can have
multiple meanings
for people in the aftermath
of genocide and conflict.
In addition to those
legal forms of justice,
we also have many
other forms of justice
that we may not even know about
or may not even know to ask.
And one of the things
I do in my research
is try to get at those other
forms and other definitions
of justice that may provide
more meaning for policy
and reconciliation programs
than the traditional forms
of justice.
So just something for us
to think about, again.
These are children at the
Nyamata Memorial Church, who
are going on an
official commemoration,
bringing their wreath,
which is really
a common thing in Rwanda.
The next theme I want to talk
about is youth and education.
So this has Gakire,
Dieudonne Gakire.
And I met Dieudonne
Gakire through a friend.
Gakire is the author of
"A Dreaming Child," which
is this phenomenal book about
young people's experiences
during the genocide in Rwanda.
And I bring up
Gakire because he is
quite representative
of the roles
that young people had to take in
the aftermath of the genocide.
Now, not every young person
is interested in the history
of genocide.
And that's normal.
But there are many people
in Rwanda, especially young
people, who are truly
interested in trying
to make sense and have
this psychological process
of meaning making of the
experiences they had,
whether they were two years old,
four years old, 10 years old,
they're still
trying to make sense
of what happened
to their families
and also educate others.
And they really take
this as a personal goal.
And Gakire's curious book
is an example of that.
Gakire was actually
invited to Bogota, Colombia
to attend the international
book fair there.
And I had been working
with him on getting grants.
And thanks to a
number of sponsors,
he was able to fly for the first
time out of Rwanda to Bogota.
And I remember being
on Facebook Messenger,
and I said, how did it go?
How was the lecture?
And he said, there
were 400 people there.
And I thought to myself,
400 people from Colombia
and other places came to hear
you speak about your book?
That's pretty incredible, and
the impact is pretty amazing.
And just to provide
a statistic, 60%
of Rwandans living in Rwanda
are under the age of 25,
like Gakire.
And so we have this heavy
burden but also opportunity
put on the youth in Rwanda.
And there are other
incredible things
that they're doing that I
can tell you about as well.
I also want to
introduce you to Henry.
Henry is one of those graduates
of Agahozo-Shalom Youth
Village in Rwanda.
You can see his
green cap and gown.
And I met Henry on my
first visit, first weekend
in Rwanda, where I was
invited to the youth village
to attend their science fair.
And Henry was
actually put in charge
of the welcoming committee,
and he welcomed me as a guest.
He didn't know me.
I didn't know him.
Those relationships you
think, OK, they're passing.
I'll meet him.
I'll go back.
I'll start my work.
It'll be fine.
It turned out that I gave
Henry my e-mail address,
and he started to write to me
as he began to apply to colleges
and asked me advice.
And I was very apt
to work with him.
He is an incredible young man.
And basically,
three years later,
Henry is now a second year
student at McGill University.
Not only did he gain admission,
but he gained scholarships
from McGill and from
private families.
And we worked together in order
to make this dream come true.
And it was pretty amazing,
because I can't tell you
the amount of times
that I said "Henry, I'm
sure this is going
to happen this year."
I said, "maybe in future
years, but as you know,
college in the West
is very expensive."
And coming from a background
where both of his parents
were killed during the genocide,
while his mother was actually
breastfeeding him and had
his twin brother on the back.
He has a twin.
And what was amazing
was, I was sitting
with these two boys on their
birthday having dinner.
And his brother,
Eric, said to me,
"Do you believe in miracles?"
And I thought to myself,
I don't really know.
I don't think about
miracles that often.
And he said, "Well,
can you imagine
that a boy from this
background in Rwanda growing up
with a grandmother in a
pretty poor neighborhood
is heading off to
McGill in a few weeks
with his visa, his
scholarship, his apartment,
and everything sorted out?"
And I said, "Yeah, it's
pretty incredible."
And he looked at me and
said, "No, this is a miracle.
It's not just
pretty incredible."
And so he really
changed my perspective.
But Henry and I are in
touch on a weekly basis,
and I'll be working with him
throughout his entire college
experience.
And I'm excited for
the opportunities
that youth have both
in Rwanda and out.
The last thing I want to mention
about youth is peace education.
And very, very briefly,
the organization
I used to work for, Aegis
Trust and the Kigali Genocide
Memorial, started this
educational program
around peace and critical
thinking for youth.
And this is another aspect of
post-genocide and post-conflict
recovery is how to reeducate
and help youth really understand
the power of their
decisions and make sure
that they can both understand
their past in order
to go forward to the future.
So this shows the
story of Eduard,
who is one of the upstanders
during the genocide.
And through pictures
and this exhibit,
and these graphic designs take
students through his story.
And then afterward, they
sit with facilitators
and go through some of the
main themes about, as I said,
critical thinking, the
power of individual choice,
and the power of living together
in the aftermath of conflict.
So the next thing
I want to touch on
is psychological healing
and trauma healing.
And as I said, I'm not
going to tell you completely
the standard stories.
This is a picture I
took when I saw and met
the all-female drumming
group, whose name is Ingoma
Nshya which means "a new drum."
And so drumming in Rwanda is
traditionally reserved for men
and prohibited from
women, who are usually
prohibited from even
touching drums or even
approaching the drummer who
used to perform for the king.
But this drum group came
about after the genocide,
with Hutu and Tutsi
women coming together
of all different ages,
of different backgrounds,
of socioeconomic backgrounds,
other backgrounds,
came together to learn
this and actually
to show that they are strong,
both physically in picking up
the drums and actually
drumming, and also
that they're strong
mentally and emotionally.
And this is a very
interesting example
of psychological health,
because it's not what we usually
think of, where people
sit in counseling groups
for individual counseling,
which takes a long time
and is very slow and is
also costly and expensive.
There are amazing things about
this kind of trauma counseling,
but in Rwanda, many
people don't access it.
And so these kinds of groups
which bring people together
are pretty incredible.
And after I saw
this performance,
I spoke to one of the
drummers and she basically
said, "You know, the group
is like a new family."
Rwandans, a lot of them
lost family, if not
entire members of their
family during the genocide.
And these newly
constructed social groups
and social networks
are incredibly
important for psychological
health and trauma healing,
because the women
also talk about what's
going on in their lives.
They celebrate together,
weddings, births, deaths.
Everything that you would expect
a family or a broader community
to do, these women do together.
And there are
others and examples
of these kinds of groups
around economic development
and other development
that have this benefit
of psychological healing.
This is a photo
that was actually
taken by a very
close friend of mine
who is a professional
photographer in Rwanda.
And if you look
closely, the photo
is of a scar on the stomach
of someone in Rwanda.
And I interviewed this person
about a year and a half ago.
And he was very shy, very quiet.
The interview didn't
last very long.
But one of the things
that really struck me
was this discussion of scars.
And I spoke to him
and said-- he told me
he was captured Interahamwe
and had some scars.
And I said to him,
can you tell me
a little bit about your scars?
And what he did was he stood
up and he lifted up his shirt
and showed me this
scar on his stomach.
After meeting him
the first time,
I went back to
interview him again,
but I was shocked at the
kind of vulnerability
of showing this
white woman in Rwanda
this scar on his stomach.
But he wanted to
make a statement,
which is that some of
the scars you can see,
both the psychological
and the physical scars,
and some you can't.
Some are hidden
under your clothes.
Some are hidden in your mind.
Some are hidden until something
triggers them and comes out.
But the scars are living
with these people,
are living with Rwandans,
and we don't know necessarily
when they're going to manifest
themselves or in what ways.
And so when working in
post-conflict societies,
we have to be very,
very almost vigilant
to the point of respect
that we can understand,
coming from non-survivor
perspectives,
how to work with
survivors and others,
including perpetrators,
who have of what happened
and what they have done.
Now, I personally
believe that all of us
have suffered some form of
trauma or some negative thing.
And it's not about comparing
hierarchies of suffering.
What happened to me is
not necessarily as bad
or doesn't feel as bad
as what happened to you
or what happened to a
survivor, but the point
is figuring out what is the
human level that we can connect
on to show the most
basic level of respect
for someone who's been
through these experiences.
And I've been very lucky to
have had the opportunity to see
scars like these, which
definitely make you
uncomfortable to have
them photographed and used
for educational
purposes, for teaching,
and also to understand that,
again, the scars don't always
come at the same time.
And so one thing I wanted
to mention about scars
as well is during
the 1994-- I'm sorry,
during the commemoration
period that starts on April 7th
every year, I often get texts
on WhatsApp or on text message
and say, "You know, Samantha,
I'm not doing well."
And I get a little concerned
and I think to myself,
"Well, I'm not a counselor,
and I've met people in Rwanda
and they're telling me that all
of a sudden something happened
and they're not doing well."
And so it's very
surprising the ways
in which people will
reach out to their friends
and other people
who they've met.
And sometimes you feel I
don't have a strong connection
with that person
but for some reason
they felt they could
trust me or maybe I
was the only one online, right?
Maybe I was the only one
online in that moment
and they wanted to
speak to someone.
But letting them know
I'm not a counselor
but I'm here as a friend.
I can advise you
in that capacity.
But it's amazing the amount
of text messages and messages
I get during this period.
And the emotional stress both
on the individual and myself,
just being very completely
honest and vulnerable with you,
but that's the responsibility
of working in this sector,
is to accept these
relationships as they are
and to try your best
to do what you can do.
And none of us is perfect
but even just being there
for someone is sometimes enough.
I had someone write to
me very late at night
and in the morning
wrote back and said, "I
was thinking of overdrinking.
And after I spoke to
you, I went to sleep
and I realized that I would
wake up tomorrow and feel maybe
a little bit better."
And all I did was take a
minute to communicate with him.
And I didn't know about any
of these thoughts in his mind,
but what was pretty incredible
was just taking that moment
to say, "Yes, I'm here.
Tell me what's up.
I'm going t have to
go in a couple minutes
to get back to work."
But whatever it
is, sometimes you
don't know the impact
of the people who
you are interacting with.
So the last point I want to
touch on is an uplifting point
and is definitely
appropriate for those
of you working at Google
and working in this sector,
is technology and research.
And one of the things that
has been happening in Rwanda
is the startup
company of Safe Motos.
So Safe Motos has helped
Rwanda separate good drivers
from what they call
the crazy ones.
Motorbikes are a very
common way to get around
in Rwanda, especially in
the capital city of Kigali.
And most of the motorbikes
are unregistered
and most accidents also
happen on motorbikes.
And so Safe Motos
has an app that's
very similar to Uber that
encourages motorbike taxi
riders to contact Safe Motos,
whose moto drivers are trained
in safety, and
there's also a record
given on how many
accidents they've had
and what kind of driving
record they have.
So not only are you able to
be picked up in a safe place,
but you're also able to know
the rating of your driver,
again, very similar to Uber.
The two founders, Peter
Kariuki and Barrett Nash.
Peter is actually a
close friend of mine,
and they're doing
amazing, amazing work.
And they also are interested
because belonging to Safe Motos
not only helps the rider but
actually helps the driver.
And moto drivers are
one of these segments
of the population that you don't
really know a lot about them.
You don't know if
they're a survivor.
You have no idea if they
were a former perpetrator.
Oftentimes, they don't
speak English or French.
It's hard for Westerners
to communicate with them
but they are a huge
segment of the population.
Many of them are coming from
villages or other places
to the capital city of
Kigali to drive a motorbike
and make money.
And so they're one of
the people that we really
don't know a lot
about, groups of people
that we really don't
know a lot about
but are heavily prevalent
in society in Kigali.
And so one of the amazing things
is that authorities are often
ambivalent towards moto
drivers, as they associate them
with crime and disorder.
But becoming part
of Safe Motos helps
them show that they're
legitimate people just trying
to make an income
and really helps
them gain legitimacy in
the eyes of authorities,
in the eyes of the
rest of society.
So it actually
has a dual purpose
in helping people ride
safely and reduce accidents
but also helping in
societal recovery,
showing that these moto drivers
are not young men coming
to create problems in the
city but they're actually
just trying to make a living
in the best way that they can.
And you can even see this is a
free concert, an advertisement
that says ride with
Safe Motos there.
So they're doing
their advertising
and saying, "You want
to come to this concert?
Great.
Ride with Safe Motos.
Be safe on your way."
It's an amazing initiative.
There's been a lot of
press on Safe Motos
and they've become a
pretty incredible startup.
But I think what's
amazing about them
is their commitment to
developing the sector of moto
drivers within the
post-conflict society
to get rid of this concept of
the young men trying to cause
problems in this city, which
is a theoretical concept
in post-conflict societies,
that the young men come
to the cities and they
want to cause problems
and they don't have
homes or education.
And this is combating
that stereotype.
And the last thing
I want to mention,
bringing it back to
memory and technology,
is the Genocide Archive
of Rwanda's new web page.
And so the Genocide
Archive of Rwanda
is able to bring access and
knowledge to individuals
around the world.
They have prescanned and
prescreened all of their data
that they put online, where
people can watch videos.
They can watch propaganda videos
of the Hutu hardline regimes
before 1994.
They can find documents.
They can take a virtual tour
of the memorial sites, which
is pretty incredible.
And these are some of
the positive things
about this website.
And some of the questions
also exists, which is how
or in what ways can
they be meaningful
for the local community
on the ground?
They have a huge reach for
people who are international
but what about survivors,
perpetrators, ordinary citizens
who are living on the
ground, who might not
have internet access,
or who might not
be interested in this
kind of education?
Who is their primary audience
and how do these issues
reconcile themselves on the
same platform, the issue
of catering to a
number of communities
and a number of individuals?
And so that's one of the things
that I think about when looking
at these online platforms or
these virtual tours of sites is
that, yes, a lot of people
cannot travel to Rwanda and see
these sites firsthand or
understand what happened
firsthand.
So they're getting
wonderful education
through a platform like the
Genocide Archive of Rwanda.
But at the same
time, we don't want
to do that at the expense
of understanding and making
memorials and other archives
meaningful for survivors
and former perpetrators.
So I'm going to end
there for a minute.
And I know I've given
you a lot of information,
a lot of stories, a lot
of food for thought.
But what I'm hoping is
that this has given you
an understanding of
Rwanda as an example
for post-conflict
societies writ large.
And one of my main, core
tenets of my research
is that we have to go deep,
and we have to go broad.
So we have to go deep to
understand that each context is
different, and that Rwanda,
what works in Rwanda, what
doesn't work in Rwanda, might
be different from another place.
But at the same time,
there are themes
that cut across
post-conflict societies
and can help us rethink
wherever we are.
And so I want you to
think back about what you
knew and believed about
post-genocide Rwanda
or post-conflict
societies writ large,
and what you've learned that
might complicate or complement
your initial thoughts.
This was not meant to be a talk
that will clarify everything
for you, rather a talk
to get you thinking
about these issues, about
the range of issues,
and about how you might
be able to fit in.
So I want to close with a
quote from one of my idols
in the world,
Desmond Tutu, which
is "Do your little bit
of good where you're at.
It's those little bits
of good put together
that overwhelm the world."
And so it's not our
responsibly to do it all,
but I hope that
today this compels
you to think about where you fit
into the post-conflict society,
even if you are sitting at
your office here in Cambridge,
or even if you travel a
little bit to some places that
might be considered
post-conflict, to delve
into their history and look
and think about what you can do
in that very, very small way,
just as I said, staying up
at night for five minutes,
WhatsApp conversation
kept a friend from overdrinking
and kept him waking up
the next morning and I'm glad
to say he's doing really well.
What are those things that
you can bring to the table?
With that, I want
to say thank you.
I want to say thank you
to the Google office
at Cambridge, to
everyone who came today.
I'm happy to take
questions and comments,
but again, I really hope this
opened your eyes to a subject
that I really care about, and
that I'm passionate about,
and that I want to
share with people
who are hopefully also
interested in these kinds
of issues.
So once again, thank you
to all of you, to Google,
and I hope you enjoyed
the talk and I am very
happy to entertain questions.
[APPLAUSE]
NADAV: Hi, can you
talk a little bit more
about transitional justice and
in the context of the Rwandan
Genocide, maybe just
give us more details
of what happened with tribunals
and the historical facts?
SAMANTHA LAKIN:
Yeah, absolutely.
So as I mentioned, I'll give you
the transitional justice 101,
which we do have a Clark
seminar on transitional justice
at Clark University.
I'm actually going to give
it to you in a minute.
Don't tell any
professor who teaches
that class that I've done this.
No, I'm just kidding.
They're my advisor.
So basically, transitional
justice, as I mentioned,
is a type of justice
that accompanies
states and societies
from conflict to peace.
It's employed in the case
of extraordinary crimes
and extraordinary grievances--
mass violence, mass atrocities.
That doesn't only mean
in number but it also
means in scale of
participation and of targeting.
So basically the concept is that
ordinary justice or ordinary
legal courts cannot really
provide justice for these
extraordinary crimes
like genocide,
crimes against humanity,
war crimes etc.
And so transitional justice has
been this array of mechanisms,
founded and used by the
international community since
the 1970s or '80s to address
some of these issues that
ordinary legal justice
cannot address.
So in Rwanda, we
see the two forms.
We see legal justice,
which I said, again,
focuses mostly on
perpetrators and punishment,
and what we call
symbolic justice, which
focuses more on
victims and survivors
and is more future-looking.
Both are important
and both must be
there in a post-conflict
society for transitional justice
to do its job.
In Rwanda, we have three
main cases that I'll mention.
One is the establishment of the
International Criminal Tribunal
for Rwanda, the ICTR, which
was established by the United
Nations Security
Council in 1995.
And this basically
was implemented
like the International Criminal
Tribunal for former Yugoslavia
and in the legacy and tradition
of the Nuremberg Tribunals
after World War II to try
the perpetrators, but not
only the perpetrators but
the big fish, the ones who
were the organizers,
the masterminds who
were instrumental in planning
and carrying out in the 1994
genocide in Rwanda.
And so the ICTR, I think, was
in operation for 20 years.
It closed in 2015.
I do have statistics on
how many people they tried,
but it wasn't too, too many.
And it was also very
difficult, because it
operates with the
bureaucracy of a tribunal.
So you have trials.
You have appeals.
You have a whole
mechanism dedicated.
The court was also
in Arusha, Tanzania.
It was not in Rwanda.
So there was outreach
about the happenings
of the court in Arusha.
There was outreach into Rwanda
but reviews are pretty mixed.
So it goes for the big
fish and it closed in 2015.
And there were some
very well-known trials
that came out of there,
including the Akayesu
case, which proved that
rape is a form of genocide,
rape is a systematic
form of genocide.
And it was the first
person convicted of rape
during genocide, Akayesu.
So in addition to
the ICTR, are we
have a form of local justice
called the Gacaca tribunals.
Now, Gacaca were typically
tribunals employed in Rwanda
for land disputes, where
people would come together
and elders or trusted
members of society
would decide what would
happen in a dispute
and in 2002, I think, or 2005,
this was re-adopte in Rwanda,
where there was a local
selection of judges,
and local individuals
would come together
in their communities,
literally on the grass.
Perpetrators would confess
what they had done,
and survivors would
forgive them or would then
have more knowledge.
One thing came out of Gacaca
was where people were buried,
which was a huge deal.
And so these Gacaca courts were
localized forms of justice.
They also have their critiques
in which the judges were not
trained judges.
There were no lawyers
or representations.
So there are questions
of due process,
but basically the
purpose was that the ICTR
and the national courts
couldn't try the large number
of perpetrators.
The prisons were
overflowing and there
had to be some practical
form of transitional justice.
And so the Gacaca courts
were formed in order
to try the lower
level perpetrators--
people involved in
property theft, people
involved in assisted killing
and murder, things like that.
So those were the Gacaca
courts, which closed in 2012.
And then we have
this third section,
which is the symbolic justice,
which are more what I discuss
and absolutely
more what I study,
which are memorializations,
commemorations, creation
of memorial sites, burial,
creation of families,
artificial families in the
aftermath of the genocide,
official apologies, security.
These are all the things I would
put under symbolic justice.
So that's the range that
transitional justice
takes specifically in Rwanda.
AUDIENCE: How do you
think our understanding
of post-conflict
societies in recovery
affects how we look
at ongoing conflicts?
SAMANTHA LAKIN: That's
a great question.
Thank you so much.
So I think it's interesting
because I was actually
speaking to my father
yesterday, who's here.
And he said, "Haven't
we learned anything?"
And I think a lot of people
ask that-- "Haven't we
learned anything?"
The 20th century is known
as the age of genocide,
the age of conflict.
Haven't we learned anything
in how we have seen and viewed
post-conflict societies and
the challenges they have?
Don't we want to prevent that?
And of course we do.
I think the difficulty,
though, is that there are so
many factors at play that when
a new conflict arises, what
worked or didn't work, for
example, in Rwanda in 1994,
in terms of intervention, may
or may not work in Syria today.
It may or may not backfire.
And that's why those local,
specialized analysts are just
as important as the ones
working at the broad level.
I think, though,
what's particularly
important is fact-finding
in post-conflict
when the conflict has subsided.
Now, of course, conflict doesn't
end when the fighting ends.
There's elements of
protracted conflict
that continue long, long after
a ceasefire agreement is signed
or fighting physically ends.
And so I think looking at
the complexities and also
the fact-finding, understanding
what really happened,
what were the patterns
of violence, what
were some of the triggers,
and analyzing these things,
analyzing propaganda
and dehumanization
tactics, groupthink and group
mentality, masculinities
and initiation into
masculizing groups,
economic problems-- all
these factors at play
help us gain a really good
understanding in hindsight
of what happened post-conflict.
How do we now apply
that to what's
going on in active conflict?
And I think that's the
million dollar question.
So I don't have a
great answer for you
but I do think that
understanding the patterns
and accurately
understanding what's
happening in current
conflicts is really important,
and doing more documentation
as the conflict's going on.
One very quick
example is Burundi.
So we have an ongoing
conflict in Burundi,
the country next to Rwanda.
And some analysts from the
State Department and elsewhere
are basically
trying to figure out
what's happening
on the ground now
and to correctly identify
what kind of violence this is
and what factors are happening.
So that when they
are deciding how
to intervene, which has been
taking a long time but I'm
hoping will happen
soon, when UN and others
Western states and other
African states and AU
are deciding what to do, if
they correctly, more or less,
identify the elements
of the problem,
they can create
better solutions.
And so that's where
I'm hoping we're
going, which is being able to
disaggregate and then build it
back, disaggregate into
themes and build it back up
to prevent.
But unfortunately, what
works in one place might not
work in other place.
And we've seen that a lot.
So I'm not trying
to be pessimistic.
I'm just trying to say
that it's a lot of work
and we have to do it well.
AUDIENCE: I like
your presentation.
As a north Rwandan who
went deep into the subject,
not only you read the
books like any other person
could read the book
but you made an impact
and will make an impact
because we have met those
you have shown us who were
victimized during the genocide.
In your experience,
it's really sad
to get to the point of
justice, as you have explained,
transitional and
the other phases,
three phases, what do you think
of bringing in justice when
we hear, the whole
world, hear people
who deny the existence
of this genocide?
And mostly, let's say we live
here in the United States
and elsewhere in Europe,
some of the perpetrators
have fled the country and
they are all over the world.
And they have come
about this denial
that the genocide
has not taken place.
Others will come
to say, "Well, we
accept that the genocide
has taken place,
but there was a
double genocide."
Another group will come
and say, well, this
is a group of the
deniers of genocide
yet they're not Rwandans.
They're not a group of
Rwandan perpetrators,
and they have not been
even in the country.
They go ahead and if I could
use the world "preach" here
and tehre about
that kind of denial.
How will you bring that
into being or bringing
a sort of justice to
these kinds of stories
around the denial of justice?
Thank you.
SAMANTHA LAKIN: Thank
you, Professor Bayingana.
Professor Bayingana brings
up a really great point,
which is what forms
does denial take
and what do we do about it?
Denial is a problem.
And it's not a new one.
We've seen it with Armenia.
We've seen it after
the Holocaust.
After almost every
major conflict,
we have people who
for some reason,
whether it's
political or personal,
cannot handle the truth of
what happened and try to give
another example.
So one way this happens
is by completely denying.
One way is by
manipulating the facts
and saying it was not a
genocide, it was a civil war.
Or, yes, Tutsi were killed in
1994 but also there were crimes
against Hutu in 1995, "96, '97.
That concept of double
genocide, that it was not only
Tutsi who were killed but after
that Hutu were killed as they
were exiting the country
and were targeted,
that's the theory
of double genocide.
And to that I would
say two things
about dealing with deniers.
One way we can deal with
deniers is to ignore them,
is not to give them
a platform to speak.
Because when deniers are
interviewed on television
or they have a chance
to write in media.
And of course,
there is free speech
in these countries
you mentioned.
People can publish
anywhere they want.
But if they're known denialists,
and if they are causing harm
to people, there are ways is
to choose someone else, someone
who maybe has a more
balanced perspective
and is not considered an
outright denialist when
any news outlet
interviews people.
One survivor told me that denial
feels like the genocide is
happening over again.
Because basically
their family were
killed during the genocide.
And then when someone
denies it, they
deny your right
of acknowledgment.
They deny your right to grieve.
They deny your right to
feel how you want to feel.
They deny what happened to
you, and they're harming
your ability to move forward
because you cannot be
recognized.
And we see this kind
of in-limbo situation
in Armenia, where
people are very
hurt because their
situation and their reality
is not being recognized.
And so I think besides
this is ignoring and not
engaging, because
denialists will keep,
as you said,
preaching, regardless
of what factual evidence comes.
I think the second point is
this categorization that's
really helpful.
I think the legal crime category
is genocide, war crimes, crimes
against humanity,
and all that has
been put into developing these
very thorough categories is
helpful.
So when the UN deemed that
Rwanda was a genocide,
there are facts and evidence in
terms of fact-finding missions,
in terms of intent,
intent to destroy
a group in whole or in part,
intent to destroy the Tutsi
people.
These were present and
proven in the case of Rwanda.
And so it is a
genocide, according
to international legal order,
if that's what you respect.
And most people, I
think most countries do.
And so sticking to
those definitions
and the facts is where
you can't go wrong.
At a certain point, if you
start getting into the emotion
and trying to convince
people, it can get very messy,
but the facts of the matter
are the ones that stick there.
And the ones that are
grounded in international law,
international theory,
that's where I think we
can really keep continuing
with helping to fight denial.
But denial is very
harmful for everyone,
and it's a big, big issue
in Rwanda right now.
So thank you so much.
Thank you, everyone.